at what point did you start to write
outside the confines of the song manizer
Song of Ice and Fire cycle and I'm
thinking here of the dunk and egg hedge
Knight stuff because that seemed I mean
that was published quite early in in was
that conceived as part of this story
that just didn't fit how did that come
about that was Robert Silverberg fault
Robert Silverberg decided he was going
to do an anthology called legends which
consisted of original stories he wanted
ten fantasy writers each writing a story
in their fantasy world an original story
never before published and he was
offering what was quite a substantial
advance er I think a record events for
story in any any anthology so and his
lineup was amazing it was you know Terry
Pratchett and Stephen King were going to
be in this and Anne McCaffrey and well
you know all of the best-selling fantasy
writers and I was just getting into my
series then I really didn't belong in
that number but I knew that I wanted to
be in this book so when he invited me to
be in this book I lethally accepted and
then I had to think well what am I gonna
write for this book I'm still in the
middle of writing I think I was still in
the middle of writing Clash of Kings I
mean the only book out then was with
Game of Thrones well am I gonna write a
story about Tyrion or are you know where
Jon Snow no I can't do that I have to
save that but a book I have to do this I
have to do a prequel so I started
thinking about my history and what would
be good area to write it and I came up
with the the duncan egg stuff I was
particularly attracted that whole story
is built around a tournament and I love
medieval tournaments and reading about
them writing about them there there's of
course some of them in the main the main
books but this this was an opportunity
in a time of peace not war to look at a
medieval teal tournament with all its
pageantry and the jousting in the calm
and reveal little of Westerosi history
and like like many other things it grew
I mean it did would I garden that I
started it and suddenly it was it was
all there actually I was so long doing
it that Bob tried to throw me out of the
book I was I was late delivering Clash
of Kings which everybody knew about and
he was approaching he'd gotten a lot of
money for this anthology and he wanted
to deliver it on the deadline so all the
stories would do at the end of the year
on December 31st and he said George I
hear you're so late from the book I
can't afford my book to be late so I'm
dropping you from the book and we're
gonna replace you and I said no you're
not I have a contract here and I'm not
late yet you may think I'm gonna be late
but I'm not late yet so you have to keep
me in the book so that's why legends
actually has eleven stories in it not
the original ten he actually replaced me
and found another guy but I refuse to be
replaced and I wrote the story and
goddamn it I got a tomb on December 31st
which is at the same time as I
understand it like five of the stories
came in so I'm not the only one that
writer who pushes things and actually I
think that story that was one of the
best decisions I ever made there was
because there was a real jump in my
sales figures between Game of Thrones
and Clash of Kings and I think that
story and legends had a lot to do it
I've had a lot of people come up to me
over the ensuing years and say I'd never
heard of you I bought legends because
there was a new Stephen King story in it
but I loved your story and I started
bringing her stuff or you know I'd never
heard of you but I bought bludgeons for
the Terry Pratchett story and then I
read your story and it was great and
that's so I think I gained a lot of a
lot of readers by being in legends do
you plan to do any more as ever as
people here read the dunk and egg
stories yeah do you plan to do any more
of them is this part of is this one of
the a project HBO I do I've written
three today
I think I need to write another I don't
know nine something like that but I have
pretty well their entire lives in my
head and of course all those things will
become more details I write them but
first I have to finish I have this book
the winds of winter you make I have to
finish that and then I can write another
Dunkin egg story and then I read a dream
of spring and then I write another
Dunkin egg story and some point in there
I have to write the second part of fire
and blood so I have my work cut out for
me why am i talking to you here I should
be home right
going back to a game of Thrones you know
when you read those first chapters that
you know you've described writing in in
the early 90s that I was very struck
with how much of the history of this
world you seemed to have already written
things that you know are recounted in
greater depth and detail in fire and
blood seemed you know Aegon's conquest
the beginning how did this world come
about what were its major political
turning points and that that's reflected
it seems to me as a reader through even
when I read the early Duncan egg stuff
you know the hedge Knight again we've
got this really strong sense of the
history of the realm of the Blackfyre
rebellion sort of hanging in the
background how much of that history did
you have to map as you went along in
order to fill out the world well I know
none of it when I began I it's been a
simultaneous process you know I wrote
that first chapter and you know names
came to me and all that I had I had some
vague sense and then when I wrote the
second chapter or the king is coming
where is he coming from at some point at
some point in that process I said hmm I
better have a map so I got out of people
piece piece of typing paper and and you
know initially I found a map of Ireland
and turned it upside down and
I put that in but I said well I don't
want it to be too visible so I'll change
some of it and then I said I can't fit
it all on this map so I'll need another
piece of typing paper so you get the
self on one piece and then north on the
other and I gradually filled them in as
I went and all that and it was the same
with the Kings and people would
occasionally mention the king or the old
king and Aegon the conquerer
well I better sit down at some point
figure out who these Kings are so I so I
won't contradict my and I made up a list
of however menteur garyun Kings there
are and dates for them and trying to
vary them and at first it was just a
list of names but as I got deeper and
deeper into it even as I'm writing about
the present day characters the the past
characters the background characters are
achieving more and more reality in in my
head and the world got progressively
more complicated